>> Jon: WELCOME TO THE DAILY
SHOW. MY NAME IS JON STEWART.
WE HAVE A VERY, VERY GOOD SHOW
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
BY POPULAR DEMAND, OUR GUEST
TONIGHT SOPHIE DELAUNAY THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF DOCTORS
WITHOUT BOARDERS, SHE IS HERE
TONIGHT TO LOOK AT THIS
THING ON MY ANKLE.
A LOVELY COURAGEOUS INDIVIDUAL
AS THEY ALL ARE.
BUT FIRST, I WANT TO FIRST TALK
TO YOU NOW ABOUT
PROFESSIONAL FUTBOL.
THE AMERICAN BRAND.
IT HAS CERTAINLY SEEN ITS SHARE
OF CONTROVERSY THIS YEAR FROM A
GAY PLAYER THAT APPARENTLY
COULDN'T HIT HARD ENOUGH IS
TO A STRAIGHT PLAYER THAT COULD
BUT PROBABLY SHOULD NOT HAVE,
SHOULDN'T OF HIT AT ALL, REALLY.
TO A TEAM THAT ON PAPER BEFORE
THE SEASON SHOULD OF
BEEN IN THE HUNT.
I MEAN, FOR GOD'S SAKES, HE'S A
TWO TIME SUPERBOWL WINNING MVP.
DO WE HAVE AN OFFENSIVE LINE, DO
WE NOT HAVE AN OFFENSIVE LINE?
AM I THE ONLY ONE WHO THINKS THE
PREDICTION SCHEMES ARE NOT ONLY
ILL-DESIGNED BUT ALSO
HILARIOUSLY UNDEREXECUTED?
THE POINT IS THIS [BEEP] ODELL
BECKHAM JR., MAN.
OKAY.
NOT A FOOTBALL CROWD.
MORE OF A JOURNALISM CROWD.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
JOURNALISM, NO. UCB, YES.
I GIVE, BY THE WAY, THE WORST
CAREER ADVICE IN THE HISTORY.
YOU KNOW WHAT YOU SHOULD DO.
YOU SHOULD YOU DROP OUT OF
SCHOOL AND START HANGING OUT
AROUND THAT IMPROV THEATER.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD DO.
THAT'S WHAT YOU SHOULD DO, LADY.
ANYWAY MY POINT IS THIS, THERE
IS MORE FOOTBALL CONTROVERSY.
>> MEMBERS OF THE ST. LOUIS RAMS
COMING ON THE FIELD WITH AN
UNEXPECTED MESSAGE.
PUTTING THEIR HANDS UP.
DON'T SHOOT.
WHAT'S BECOME A SYMBOL OF THE
PROTESTS FOLLOWING FERGUSON.
>> Jon: SYMBOLE OF THE PROTESTS?
IT'S FOOTBALL. I'M PRETTY SURE
THEY'RE JUST GOING,
HEY FELLAS LET'S SCORE SOME
TOUCH DOWNS.
OR MAYBE THEY'RE JUST PREPARING
TO DANCE AT TEVYE'S DAUGHTER'S
WEDDING.
♪ SUBMISSION
♪ I'VE GOT NO GUN, SUBMISSION
A RARE INSTANCE OF SOCIAL
AWARENESS FROM THE NFL.
JOINING IN A COMMON SIGNAL OF
SOLIDARITY.
LIKE THAT "HUNGER GAMES" KATNISS
THREE FINGER SALUTE.
OF COURSE, OBVIOUSLY THE
DISTRICT 11 RESIDENTS WHO HELD
UP THEIR HANDS LIKE THAT WERE
IMMEDIATELY ATTACKED BY THE
POLICE, WHICH IS WHERE
OUR METAPHOR -- ALRIGHT.
ANYWAY, WHY IS THIS A BIG DEAL?
>> THE ST. LOUIS COUNTY
POLICE ASSOCIATION CALLING THE
GESTURE TASTELESS, OFFENSIVE
AND INFLAMMATORY.
THEY WANT THE NATIONAL FOOTBALL
LEAGUE TO APOLOGIZE AND TO
PUNISH THE PLAYERS.
>> TO US IT SEEMS LIKE RATHER
THAN ALLOWING WOUNDS TO HEAL
THAT THEY'RE FOLKS PICKING
AT THE SCABS.
[BOOING]
>> Jon: HOLY [BEEP].
SO THE ST. LOUIS POLICE
ASSOCIATION IS ANGRY AND
OUTRAGED TO HAVE BEEN CAUGHT
IN THIS HAIL OF GESTURES AND
FEELS THAT THE COMMUNITY WON'T
GET PAST THIS TRAGIC PANTOMINE
UNLESS SOMEONE IS
HELD ACCOUNTABLE.
THAT'S THE ANGLE THEY'RE GOING
WITH.
ALRIGHT.
ST. LOUIS RAMS COACH, JEFF
FISHER.
>> THEY WILL NOT BE DISCIPLINED
BY THE CLUB NOR WILL THEY
BE DISCIPLINED BY THE
NATIONAL FOOTBALL LEAGUE.
>>Jon: LET ME ASK YOU A
QUESTION WHEN DID NICK NOLTE
TAKE OVER THE RAMS.
YEAH, FISHER THAT WILL TEACH
YOU TO DO THE RIGHT THING!
A NOLTE JOKE. HE'S A RAGTOP
COACH.
ALRIGHT, SO I GUESS WE'VE GOT
OURSELVES AN OLD FASHION POLICE
DEPARTMENT PROFESSIONAL FOOTBALL
TEAM STAND OFF.
WHO IS GOING TO BLINK?
>> THE RAMS CHIEF OPERATING
OFFICER CALLED THE ST. LOUIS
POLICE CHIEF CALLED TO
APOLOGIZE FOR THE RAMS' HANDS UP
DON'T SHOOT GESTURE DURING
SUNDAY'S GAME.
>> Jon: OH, I THOUGHT, ACTUALLY
I THOUGHT THEY WERE NOT
GOING TO APOLOGIZE.
>> THE RAMS OFFICIAL, HOWEVER,
NOW DENIES APOLOGIZING.
HE SAYS IN PART IN NONE OF THESE
CONVERSATIONS DID I APOLOGIZE
FOR OUR PLAYERS' ACTIONS.
>> Jon: ISN'T IT INTERESTING HOW
WITNESS TESTIMONY IS SO
UNRELIABLE. WELL, HOW CAN WE,
HOW CAN WE IN ANY WAY
HOW CAN WE CLEAR THIS UP?
HOW DO WE CLEAR IT UP?
>> IN A TESTY AND BIZARRE
EXCHANGE OF TWEETS AND
STATEMENTS OVER NIGHT POLICE
CLAIM THE RAMS APOLOGIZED.
BUT THE RAMS SAID NO.
THEN THE POLICE TWEETED THE
DEFINITION OF APOLOGY INCLUDING
WORDS "EXPRESSION OF REGRET."
>> Jon: AND THEN, AND THEN THE
RAMS TWEETED
WTF POLICE? #UNFOLLOW AND THEN,
AND THEN
THE POLICE WERE ALL, THANKS
OBAMA #NOTALLCOPS. AND THEN,
AND THEN THE RAMS WERE LIKE THIS
COULD BE US, BUT YOU PLAYING.
[LAUGHING]
LISTEN, I SEE THE
CONFUSION HERE.
THE RAMS MADE THE SORRY IF YOU
WERE OFFENDED NON-APOLOGY NOBODY
EVER BELIEVES IS AN ACTUAL
APOLOGY AND INSTEAD OF REJECTING
THE NON-APOLOGY OUTRIGHT LIKE A
NORMAL GROUP, THE COPS CONFUSED
THINGS EVEN MORE ACCEPTING IT
FORCING THE RAMS TO CLARIFY
THE PASSIVE AGGRESSIVE NATURE
OF THEIR ORIGINAL NON-APOLOGY
WHICH MEANS AT LEAST FINALLY IN
THIS COUNTRY
WE'RE HAVING THE IMPORTANT
NATIONAL CONVERSATION ABOUT
SEMANTICS, WE NEED.